However, there are some gotcha's here.
What happens, for example,
if the length of the document is zero?
All of sudden, you have divided by zero.
>> Right.
>> Okay.
>> So we would have to consider that as
a special case.
Also, what exactly do we mean
by the size of the handle?
As we said,
we probably from the GUI toolkit would
get some pixels, a number of pixels.
But we'd need to translate that into
something like a percentage, or
an integer count of things.
And then there's an even
more subtle situation.
Let's say that we've scrolled
to the end of the file.
>> Okay.
>> And we re-sized the window
to make it bigger.
>> Okay.
>> What happens?
What do we expect to
see in the viewport?
So one possibility is we would
see exactly the same lines, but
now some blank lines at the bottom.
>> Okay.
>> Another possibility is
that the line that was at
the bottom of the viewport before stays
at the bottom of the viewport, and
we see some more lines at the top.
And, in fact, if you go play around
with actual web browsers out there, and
with word processing editors and so on,
you can see both of these behaviors.
However, if we're
designing the application,
we have to make the decision about
which one of those two behaviors
we actually intend that
the text browser to have.
Okay?
So, this process of modeling has forced
us into thinking about something
which we might not have,
otherwise, thought about,
which is one of the benefits
of doing the modeling.
It forces you to think
through subtleties of things.